[Music]
for decades people who want to control
their weight have been told to count
calories given that the great majority
of diets fail is this good advice kid
the calorie be one of the biggest
delusions in dietary history the idea of
counting calories was introduced by
Wilbur Atwater
he believed that a calorie is a calorie
his theory was that a calorie provided
the body with an equal amount of energy
no matter what kind of food or
micronutrient that came from he
concluded that one gram of either
protein or carbohydrate provided four
calories of energy compared with nine
through one gram of fat and more than a
century later that series of numbers for
4/9 remains in standard use around the
world today to calculate the energy that
we get from foods
well what atwater didn't factor in at
the time was that different people learn
different foods at different rates
depending on their genetic makeup or
variables such as the type of bacteria
in an individual's gut and cooking food
will increase the amount of calories a
person can absorb from it Atwater's
findings led to the misconception that
fact always leads to more weight gain
than other foods including sugar this
theory has shaped dietary policy in the
West for decades in fact if excess sugar
is in the bloodstream then insulin
stacks it straight into fatty tissue
making eating sugar the fastest way to
create body fat the fault is not
entirely Atwater's in 1967 the sugar
industry secretly funded Harvard
University research designed to point
the blame for rising obesity levels at
fat rather than sugar this led the US
Senate and many other governments to
recommend a low-fat low-cholesterol diet
that advice coincided with the most
dramatic rise in obesity in human
history contributing to a rapid rise in
cardiovascular diseases which have
become the leading cause of death
worldwide Atwater's assumptions have
become so deeply entrenched in society
that many demon over all of the system
too disruptive and expensive but more
than a century on it's time to bury the
world's most useless measure
you